okay so uh another
campus that i want to um
that i'd like to make an appearance on
we're trying we're still trying to
trying to set it up if we can is
university of north texas and we talked
about that yesterday to start the show
the total
satanic meltdown that ensued at
university of north texas
um
because somebody showed up on campus and
gave a talk about why
children should not be castrated
why it's you know why we shouldn't be
butchering gender confused children and
it just so happens that the guy that was
giving the talk jeff younger
is a father who's who has been trying to
rescue his own son
from
this barbarity
and but has been has been prevented from
doing that by the courts who have given
uh custody over to the mom because the
mom is gender affirming which is to say
the mom is going to go along with her
kid being being um
abused and mutilated
and this was enough for the for the
people on campus to for the kids on
campus and the lgbt activists to lose
their mind i mean it really did watching
some of the footage and we played some
of it yesterday i have another clip
we'll play again we'll play here
but watching the footage it really does
remind you as i'm so often reminded
when i see these kinds of temper
tantrums from the left
it it does kind of harken back to to the
exorcist it's like this demonic you
almost expect to see their heads turning
around 360 degrees start vomiting green
slime all over the place levitating like
you expect to see that
because they're just filled with satanic
rage
at the idea that anybody would try to
protect kids from being butchered
so before we have an update here from
the daily wire
here's one clip we didn't play yesterday
um
and this is one when it comes to liberal
meltdowns i think this is one that will
that will live in infamy this is almost
as good you know the the the most famous
liberal meltdown of course is that right
after trump was elected in dc the the
infamous footage of the woman falling to
her knees and shouting no up into the
sky um this is almost as good as that
watch this
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
i don't know what else can you do but
laugh
you know you see that it's it's easy
enough to see that and think well look
mental illness is a real problem in this
country
and uh clearly this is someone who's
mentally deranged
and and meant and yes that's that's true
i'm not denying that
um these are not mentally stable people
but
we have to realize that the the mental
illness um is not you know they they
weren't born with it
um this is something that has been
they've been conditioned into it it's
been implanted in their minds
and through the the conditioning through
the you know the gender theory gender
ideology conditioning
but also through through this sense of
entitlement
that they've been
you know conditioned into that they've
that they've grown up with
they've
these kids have been coddled to such an
extent
that for even one person
to say something they disagree with it
isn't it
they they can't handle it they don't
know how to handle it
they don't know how to handle someone
disagreeing with them what they could
have done i mean that whole room
was full of people on the other side of
it it was full of people who disagree
with jeff younger
so what they could have done
is just
not showed up and gone about their lives
and from the looks of it you know jeff
younger would have been talking to an
empty room mostly
but to eat the knowledge to to know
that there is someone in their vicinity
saying things
expressing views that are not their own
just the the knowledge of that they they
they can't handle it
they're compelled to show up and they
don't have any arguments to present
obviously all they can do is just scream
in infantile rage
at the idea that
anyone is allowed to disagree with them
as i said yesterday you know we we like
to comfort ourselves on the right we've
been comforting ourselves uh far too
often speaking of being coddled we've
kind of tried to cuddle ourselves a
little bit and comfort ourselves by by
saying that uh you know
these kids they'll
they're in for a for a rude awakening
when they you know go out into the world
and
um they're going to encounter the real
world and they're going to they're going
to get over this pretty quickly that's
not the case
unfortunately
because they're going out into a world
that they are also shaping
i mean
this is the next generation they're
they're taking over
and so that sense of entitlement all of
it
it's it's not going anywhere
it's just going to metastasize
maybe for some of them i hope there will
be there will be an awakening of sorts
but it's not going to be a necessary
awakening there's nothing about the
quote real world right now
that would require them
to um awake from this stupor
from this self-centered narcissistic
stupor
in fact our entire culture is designed
now
to continue to coddle these people
that's a scary thought
it's a scary thought for a lot of
reasons one of them is that um
you know those the kids are not in that
room there
if somebody had just gone up and shot
jeff younger in the head
how do you think the kids would have
responded
you think they would have been upset to
see that
no that kind of rage it's because they
want you dead i mean they think that you
should be dead and and oftentimes
they're quite clear about that
they think that you should be dead for
disagreeing with them
that's how they they think that's what
they believe and they are taking that
belief with them into the greater into
the outside world
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated